what's up Theo Macho Man Randy average
and Brendon the Punishers gage one
brother what's more likely to pull the
ladies playing the guitar or playing the
piano the piano you need the boy hendrix
versus billy goat the the angus young
versus another dude that plays the PM
personally i think it's the guitar
curious what you think gangrene buzz
aldrin I love this kid and I met Buzz
Aldrin once did you and he looked like
he hadn't been to the moon man believe
him when I looked in his eyes and I've
said this before when I looked in his
eyes he didn't look like somebody who'd
been to the moon now let's let's just
let the listeners know you also don't
think joe exotic is gay so take it for
what for what it's worth that boy's
[ __ ] [ __ ] Topanga Canyon definitely
curve you're gay Susie is uh yeah
Joe exotic I think he's gay but I think
he's I think it's converting them
straight boys I think that's hard to do
and again the work ethic bro he's
relentless
that's my psyche I just do it dude just
like an iPod Tigers after just doing
he's the Lance Armstrong of gays mm-hmm
unstoppable leader everybody was [ __ ]
over Tigers he just did it better
dude I know this video you know he heard
his like he shot himself in the [ __ ]
leg dude oh is that what you got it's
not great at the head that video and I
bet after that he just used it as a
every now and then if [ __ ] went haywire
you just shoot himself in the [ __ ]
leg to get attention yeah oh yeah I'll
do it
it was great when he started just firing
that pistol there yeah in a studio your
balls that man has you man I like what
the [ __ ] you doing
cops would come good luck getting
through the Tigers yeah
how about when they're like we're gonna
shut you down I said good luck getting
through and what waving this white flag
you have to kill me get me out of here
with my Tigers like [ __ ] yeah Joe
that's crazy a man was brave there was a
lot going on man what about when they
open that pizzeria with them meat from
the Walmart truck about I love a good
just a real businessman who just stellar
I would invest in that zoo oh yeah now
that's a zoo I go in on Newt if we
started at pet petting zoo withdraw
exotic heavy a pet can make animals you
could imagine out of Britain dude we
just invested and marketed for him yeah
[ __ ] he calls in over the PA system from
prison out of y'all yeah yeah wait daddy
definitely good Martha that's an easy
man guitars that panty-dropper pianos
that [ __ ] booty drop burn I think it
used to be a panty dropper I think now
it's definitely piano more I think the
guitar we're getting back anymore the
piano times John Legend had something to
do with that but then dude you see a
[ __ ] nice young man ripping on that
[ __ ] just shred city I'll be joy
exotic in that [ __ ] just like what you
got a tiger next year dude I'm suck it
what do you guys think let's go to the
culture corner and get some talk really
yeah you forget it's not a mixtape cuz
that she was straight mixtape did you
get a deal I recorded off GarageBand did
you get a did you get a record deal
well I had to get it back first and then
to get the record deal but I don't have
one yeah yeah still shopping it around
gems a musician what do you think guitar
[ __ ] piano well I've played both for
girls in front of girls and guarantee
it's the guitar cuz the piano usually
fits piano you're facing the wall
alright if it's in a house oh yeah I put
that [ __ ] on top like this
it's how I get face right in front of
them and look in their eyes and sing
yeah be conjoined piano
look at me chin you'd like I'm like
if you're already on the piano then that
means I don't have to do anything
yardie yeah my girl yeah I used to play
a piano at night from jeffrey dahmer mom
I don't have to play all right I could
see you I could see you on the piano or
guitar thank you you can play both - I'm
better at guitar breaking playboys yeah
Jen's super talented
you also start a [ __ ] band that's
what I'm saying me and seal and market
it yeah we did you call it rush hour
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah Nick and rap on it well we all
know I feel bad for his neck rapping
that's you know how he knows you he win
in yeah what do you think cat from a few
in perspective what instrument some dude
can you come over here as a piano laid
out or he has a [ __ ] guitar he's like
what's up girl obviously drive a tow
truck yeah
the piano is that laid out somewhere
those floor pianos burning that like you
clean up all oh well he this the other
thing freedom to you could have one of
those electric pianos keep mistress in
his lap there's beats were horrible do
that solves a shins problem he can look
in the eyes that way if you just got
that small one true but they gotta plug
it in somewhere you get batteries no
batteries
you gotta plug that guitar in whose
Allegro know goes to stick about that
John Mayer
yeah always acoustic not a lecture dude
girl gets that John Mayer she has a
classic [ __ ] thinking guitar tits out
do I make
that's wifey crazy yeah brother probably
what do cats a yeah you have to go with
guitar because if one I think a keyboard
looks silly like if it dude brought out
keyboard and started playing I really
like friend friendzone not necessarily a
dude I want to go out with
yeah keyboard will get you into the
friend zone ya know it's kind of hard to
bring around anywhere it's like you're
trying a little bit but if a guy pushes
it over brings it over with his car
pulls it over he's sweating has to cut
out jean shorts
Joe exotic but up but also if a dude's
play the piano it's a super intimate to
if you seem like some John Legend like
all of you like it's real serious but
you can't have fun on the on the [ __ ]
piano guitar you get loose man Stevie
Wonder has fun yeah he's the greatest
musician of all time yeah you could take
your legs on dude
Vienna will make you feel like you could
take your damn legs off dude yeah so
just you blind
yeah imagine that dude you could see and
then suddenly the music so good you just
go [ __ ] blind
praise God [ __ ] yeah what does guy wanna
know King and so we we said guitar
everybody seems like easily what was the
vote on that I'm gonna roll piano man
[ __ ] no I wish I could play either
though well can you play any instrument
have you ever tried yeah I used to play
a guitar a little bit and I and I've
played the piano I can play the piano
okay if I have music in front of me
did somebody teach you or you just pick
them I just learned at home just go do
those well you're creative dude they got
these books they're pretty easy it's not
that hard you seven have a lot of time
and you got to have read some real
patients you got a real gift when I was
playing rock man did you I did it I
don't know what it was I just felt like
a me my boys get together I was on them
drums
dude I felt like [ __ ] flee on that
[ __ ] I just see you in the rooms as
[ __ ] tracks base promise Barker
I can see you're doing drugs like a
drummer I would love to be a drummer
yeah I'll have my shirt off I put that
[ __ ] bandanna and a flag around your
necktie African American flag yeah like
a choke collar and then a bandana shirt
off sweat and just rock on your neck
yeah yeah that too that we knew that's
what they did like flea you got to go
hard right they be awesome and you play
the bass
[Music]